we were just talking about california
and their
the state of
everything at the moment aren't they
just about to increase the taxes again
uh yes i believe there is
some kind of proposal on the board to
double the taxes because they're trying
to do
the first um like single-payer
healthcare system on a statewide level
for
everyone no matter your immigration
status no matter
i mean everyone basically
anyone
you get health care and you get health
care and look i think our health care
system in america is it is
uh a disaster of epic proportions in
many ways and if you don't have help
navigating it or you're not rich it it's
challenging and it's bankrupted people
and
there's no transparency you just you
don't you know something costs
there's no like clear-cut cost it's like
if you have insurance it costs this if
you have cash maybe you can get it for
this and
it feels very crazy to me so
um in terms of like and then like mental
health care you know just you can't get
if you move states you can't see the
therapists that you're seeing in the
other state if they're not licensed and
all this occupational licensing which is
insane and
it just um
it seems very
overly complicated one of the things i
noticed while i was out in austin was
the the homeless people that were there
like american homeless people have
another level of crazy to them so we
have homeless here in the uk you know
but
i've been around a lot of homeless
people i work in nightlife so i've been
the only people out at 2am uh club
promoters people in parties and the
homeless they've been around them an
awful lot unsupervised on the street
maybe when they've had a bit to drink or
whatever else
but walking just down the street in
austin near an underpass
and
these
guys will be talking to themselves
they're pushing something along they're
really sort of jittery and forthcoming
and aggressive it made me i don't get
nervous around people very much but yeah
there's another
like level of crazy now imagine being a
pregnant woman walking around a city
like that
um
and it's everywhere yeah there's another
it certainly seems to me like that's
been aggravated as well
i don't know if it's the drugs i don't
know if it's
um
the society
a combination of all those factors
but the
number i there is not a single day that
goes by that i don't walk my dog and
or go out and do errands and have to
kind of
invade someone evade or cross the street
or
completely reroute from someone who's
clearly talking to themselves
you're like i don't know i don't i just
i don't
does it matter where you go is this
pretty much across most neighborhoods
now in l.a
uh yeah it's pr it's everywhere i mean
some better than others obviously i'm
not i'm not living in a gated community
and even those communities are being
affected by like armed robberies and
things that were kind of unheard of
so they're getting more
i think
like robberies car break-ins and
uh violent crime that's happening
perfect time for double taxes yes i know
yes i know
so yeah it seems kind of crazy to me we
were talking about this on dumpster fire
my dumb little
like whatever it is show
and
we were saying like is this just a way
to punish the people who have stayed in
california
you didn't heed the signs idiots
hey idiots if you need another reason i
know and it's so hard as you know i'm a
small business owner now technically
and
it's hard i i just with payroll taxes
and the actual taxes and then yesterday
we got a letter from ladwp which is our
water and power and these these
companies operate like
um mafias because they have no
accountability and no competition so
they get to just do whatever they want
and they're like oh you your water was
in like this category for one month out
of 12 months and we're just letting you
know that
water is going up if you're in this
category and
they don't
they don't
have any resources devoted to collecting
water like this is the gut they've
caused this problem and they they pass
it off to
their
the people who are using water and they
should be [ __ ] me
it's craziness yeah and there's nothing
again no transparency you don't know
like
where that water is coming from or
what it's just it's craziness it's
in the
yeah i mean don't even get me started on
like the grids burning all the
the forest down and literally nobody is
accountable for that ever
we were saying about how crazy it is
that certain people leave you realize
there's people that have been in certain
cities for their entire life malice
leaving new york for me that was the
biggest red flag that anyone could have
waved because that guy was in love with
that city oh that's like um
carol markowitz as well i don't know
that she's another person she's a writer
and uh um she was at the new york post
and she she was like the die hard new
yorker i mean she really
again like
comes from a russian family very much
like malice i think they know each other
and she was just
in love with brooklyn and new york and
when i would see her there she would
take me to all these cool spots and she
just
absolutely loved that city and they left
for florida and i was like i'm you know
if you have stock in new york you should
be selling it right now
so bad yeah i mean like for michael to
leave that said pretty much everything
that i needed to know
but it's
everything that i see i'm not in these
cities right i haven't been to la in a
couple of years i've been to new york in
a couple of years oh i'm going to be
there in a couple of weeks actually so i
guess i'll get to see a little bit of it
on the ground
i think why
why would you let the city get to this
stage like if it if it's people that
like podcasters and
normal people
tweeting on the streets if they have a
problem with it let alone the public
policy people that are supposed to
actually have aspirations for these
cities
why why why is it they don't care do
they not know what they're doing is it
negligent is it malignant is it
malicious
i i don't actually know because
i would have an answer and then a lot of
other people would have a different
answer they would say
i would say i think it's a combination
of incompetence
compensation
in california new york these are single
rule you know single party
ruled states where there dominantly
is no balance or competition
so there's
very little
it's all just progressive policies and
you know michael michael shellenberger
does a really great job i think of
recently looking at how these
progressive policies however
well-intentioned they might be
um
are destroying these cities and i'd
prefer to try and
give people the benefit of the doubt and
and say
these
come from good intentions although if
you're
on the right wing and in certain
factions of it you'll say this is part
of it they like in in an attempt to
achieve some kind of utopia
you've got to let some cities burn and
some people die and that's just part of
the process so it's it's like
this
from
from a right-wing kind of
perhaps hyperbolic perhaps not
perspective
this is what communism does goddamn
globalists man
you're done [ __ ] against commies it's
those commies and you know we in color
camifornia
and
it's it's
it's
funny because it's kind of true
so
and i don't know enough about these
things i just don't i can only observe
it from like a working class perspective
man on the street and
you know that the idea that people can
just move is
also one that i
bristle at sometimes when people are
like just move just move i'm like it's
not that easy for everyone to just up
and move
if you have family in in this town if
you're not wealthy it costs a lot of
money to move
these other places where you might move
to are
now
like austin's not cheap anymore it's
certainly not as cheap as it was many
years ago
and
do you want to pay
um exorbitant amounts to move and be
away from your family
and you're moving to a place usually
that has you know not as great weather i
mean there's always a cost benefit
analysis you're making but
i also think that's kind of like an
upper class solution and the working
class doesn't always have that mobility
or ability
or just disposable income
so when people are like oh you're in
california just move i'm like well okay
i'm not a millionaire you know i'm not
i'm not in that we we're about to have a
child my mother-in-law lives here
if i move somewhere do i dis
dislodge my self from like my whole
system of support which is invaluable
would you be able to take your staff
with you as well
um they would come yeah i mean it's
really just my cousin it's not like um i
have this ginormous staff either like
some of these other companies that have
left la um
and
so yeah i think that would that's not
really a problem we're still pretty like
lean and
mean but
it's more just the things that you can't
really put money on you know
if i move to like texas for instance
which we are thinking about
i now have no family support no i'm now
needing to pay for health care i'm
paying for a move
i'm
like not a huge fan of the weather down
there i know people are like oh it's
fine i just always joke i'm like don't
ever take advice from rich people about
this stuff when they're like it's fine
you won't even notice i'm like you have
a pool
you have like a central air conditioned
pool house like with boats and you know
i'm not i'm not in that same league i'm
going to be in just like some freaking
house on the flatlands and the outskirts
uh i don't have the same resources
available to me to make i like my my
neighborhood would probably be the
neighborhood where the
the grid goes down and the ice storm
yeah
yeah what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace